Что нужно делать для зарабатывания
больших денег? Пахать или не пахать?
Если вам эта тема интересна, ставьте
лайк, подписывайтесь, а мы пойдём
дальше. Многие люди упрощают эт вопрос,
и они смотрят: "Либо пахать, либо не
пахать. На самом деле нужно пахать, но
просто нужно знать, где и сколько
пахать. Давайте я приведу вам пример.
Вот в чём фокус и вообще в чём отличие
богатых людей или успешных людей от
неуспешных людей? Дело в том, что
успешных людей от неуспешных людей
отличает не то, что они что-то делают
по-другому. Вот есть распространённый
миф или а-а распространённое
утверждение, что богатые люди делают всё
по-другому. На самом деле, в чём суть
того, что они делают по-другому? Вы
думаете, они у них маркетинг строится
по-другому? Нет. Тот же самый маркетинг.
Продажи по-другому? Нет. Маркетинг и
продажи то же самое. Людей они нанимают
по-другому. то же самое. То есть все,
всё, что касается бизнес-инструментов,
они делают то же самое, что и вы. Другой
вопрос, что они делают по-другому? А
другое они делают то, что они держат
фокус на ключевых точках. Они занимаются
ключевыми вещами. Так вот, ответом на
вопрос пахать или не пахать, я приведу э
такую метафору или расскажу в виде
истории. Представьте, что вы строите
сорокаэтажный небоскрёб. Если вы в
фундаменте допустите маленькую трещинку,
то эта трещина приведёт вас на сороковом
этаже к катастрофе. Здесь работает
закон, который гласит: маленькая ошибка
в начальных условиях всегда приводит к
катастрофе в конце. Именно поэтому,
когда вы строите большой небоскрёб, вы
должны быть перфекционистом и пахарем на
стадии строительства фундамента и
первого, и второго этажа. Почему на
стадии фундамента? Вам, наверное, и так
понятно, да? Потому что фундамент должен
быть реально идеальный. А почему на
стадии первого, второго этажа? Потому
что это те этажи, которые видны, которые
люди могут пощупать, в которых находятся
коммерческие помещения. Они могут
пощупать, сравнить материал, и через
этот материал, который вы применили при
строительстве, они могут судить о
качестве всего здания. Поэтому
фундамент, первый и второй этаж - это
наиболее критическая часть здания. И вот
здесь вы должны пахать как угорелый. И
вот здесь вы должны быть не просто
перфекционистом, а параноиком.
Дальше, чем выше, больше этажей вы
строите, тем больше вы делегируете на
команду. больше, больше, больше она там,
начиная от тридцать пятого этажа или до
сорокового этажа, там уже полностью
команда может сама строить. Причём может
сделать из пенопласта. Это эти этажи,
они всё равно снизу не видны, а
непонятно,
никто не может пощупать, посмотреть и
так далее. Поэтому критичная часть - это
начальные, э, начальная часть. Давайте
сравним, а, посмотрим на бизнес. Когда
вы начинаете бизнес, вы как основатель
должны определить ключевой фактор
успеха, что является ключевым вашем
бизнесе. Раз. Во-вторых, вы должны
сформировать команду. В-третьих, вы
должны дать миссию компании и всей
команде объяснить смысл, зачем мы вместе
собрались и что мы делаем, для кого мы
делаем. Четвёртых, вы должны создать
корпоративную культуру или культуру
взаимоотношений в компании. В пятых, вы
должны прописать первые, э,
взаимоотношения с там генеральным
директором, которого вы наймёте, или
вашим помощником, или, может быть,
заместителем и так далее. То есть вы
закладываете основу вашей будущей
компании. В это время вам надо пахать и
в это время на вам надо быть
перфекционистом. А дальше по мере роста
развития компании уже многие вещи будут
делаться самими сотрудниками. Если взять
опять это здание как пример, то
смотрите, во всём здании, если вы пашете
на стадии фундамента первого, второго
этажа, а дальше меньше и меньше, то люди
со стороны скажут: "Вот сорокоэтажное
здание Маргулан построил, из них он
только 20% максимум пахал, 80% сделала
команда. И это будет правда". Но в этих
20%, которые я пахал, я пахал там 100%
времени на стадии фундамента первого,
второго этажа. То есть нужно понимать,
когда вы должны пахать на 100% и где вы
должны быть перфекционистом. И нужно
понимать, когда уже вашего участия
такого не требуется. Поэтому на вопрос
пахать или не пахать, я твёрдо отвечаю.
Вам нужно пахать на всех ключевых
точках. И вам нужно быть перфекционистом
во всех ключевых точках. Всё остальное
вы можете делегировать, вы можете
привлекать подрядчиков сторонних, вы
можете привлекать поставщиков и так
далее, и так далее, если это не ключевое
для вашего бизнеса. Så